>> Tucker: NOT SO LONG AGO, IT
WAS A FEATURE OF HIGH SCHOOL
BIOLOGY CLASS THAT BIOLOGICAL
SEX IS BIOLOGICALLY REAL, IT IS
DETECTABLE AT THE DNA LEVEL, YOU
ARE BORN WITH IT.
YOU DON'T GET TO CHOOSE IT.
JUST LIKE YOUR EYE COLOR,
HEIGHT, SUSCEPTIBILITY TO
BREAST CANCER OR A MILLION OTHER
THINGS, IT IS GENETIC.
GENETICS ARE REAL, MAYBE
UNFORTUNATELY, BUT IT DOESN'T
CHANGE THE TRUTH OF IT.
BUT NOW, THAT'S HATE SPEECH.
IN HIS NEW SPECIAL,
DAVE CHAPPELLE THE COMEDIAN
EXPLAINS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
CHALLENGE THIS LUNATIC NEW
ORTHODOXY.
>> CANCELED PEOPLE THAT ARE MORE
POWERFUL THAN ME.
YOU CANCEL J.K. ROWLING, MY GOD,
J.K. ROWLING, WELL, ALL THE
"HARRY POTTER" BOOKS BY HERSELF.
SHE SOLD SO MANY BOOKS THE BIBLE
WORRIES ABOUT HER.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THEY CANCELED HER BECAUSE
SHE SAID IN AN INTERVIEW, THIS
IS NOT EXACTLY WHAT SHE SAID,
BUT ESSENTIALLY SHE SAID GENDER
WAS A FACT.
AND THEN THE TRANS COMMUNITY GOT
MAD AS [BLEEP] AND STARTED
CALLING HER A TURF, I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT THE [BLEEP] THAT WAS.
BUT I KNOW THAT TRANS WILL MAKE
UP WORDS TO WIN ARGUMENTS.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT IS THE
TRUEST THING EVER THING, THEY
MAKE UP WORDS TO WIN ARGUMENTS,
YOU SEE THAT IN A LOT OF PLACES.
AND ON ABOUT AS RADICAL,
CONVENTIONAL, FOUR YEARS AGO NO
ONE WOULD HAVE NOTICED IT.
BUT NOW, A NUMBER OF NETFLIX
EMPLOYEES HAVE DECIDED TO
PROTEST THE SPECIAL.
THEY WANTED PULLED OFF THE
SERVICE.
THEN THEY HARASSED A MAN WHO
CAME TO SUPPORT CHAPELLE AND
FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
WATCH.
[CHANTING]
>> IT'S OKAY TO LAUGH, BUT YOU
ARE SPARKING HATE CONVERSATION.
>> WHY ARE YOU BREAKING MY SIGN?
>> [BLEEP].
>> HE'S GOT A WEAPON!
>> Tucker: SO THEY BREAK HIS
SIGN, THEN THEY ACCUSE HIM, HE
IS LEFT HOLDING A STICK, ACCUSE
HIM HOLDING A WEAPON.
SO HIS SPEECH IS VIOLENCE, THEIR
VIOLENCE IS SPEECH, SEE HOW THAT
WORKS?
WHAT IS INTERESTING IS THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO REALLY CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE ENOUGH TO
ASSAULT SOMEONE OVER IT IS TINY,
YET THEY HAVE DISPROPORTIONATE
POWER.
350 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY, MAYBE 1100 FEEL THAT
WAY AND THEY ARE RUNNING
EVERYTHING, WHY IS THAT?
SETH DILLON MAY KNOW THAT
ANSWER, THE BABYLON BECOME A ONE
OF THE VERY FEW REMAINING SATIRE
SITES ON THE ENTIRE
INTERNET, HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SETH, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON, THE STUFF IS IN YOUR
FACE EVERY SINGLE DAY, YOU ARE
THE TARGET OF A LOT OF THIS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, THE PEOPLE
TRYING TO DESTROY YOUR BUSINESS
AND YOUR LIFE, THEY ARE A TINY
PERCENTAGE OF AMERICANS, AREN'T
THEY?
>> THEY ARE, BUT THEY WIELD ALL
THE POWER.
THIS IS THE FUNNY THING.
THEY REALLY ARE A JOKE AT THIS
POINT BECAUSE THEY TRY TO
PROJECT THEMSELVES AS BEING
MARGINALIZED.
THESE ARE THE MARGINALIZED,
THESE ARE THE OPPRESSED.
YOU CAN'T MAKE FUN OF THEM.
THE WAY THAT YOU CAN TELL WHO
HOLDS ALL THE POWER IN A SOCIETY
IS BY WHO YOU CAN'T MAKE FUN OF,
RIGHT?
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THESE ARE THE PEOPLE YOU
CAN'T MAKE FUN OF.
IT IS CLEAR THEY HOLD ALL THE
INSTITUTIONAL POWER IN OUR
CULTURE AND IT IS VERY
INTERESTING WHEN YOU HAVE
COMEDIANS LIKE CHAPELLE, YOU
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT NOW, TELLING
JOKES, YOU DON'T JUST ASK
YOURSELF, IS THIS FUNNY?
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, IS
THIS JOKE GOING TO OFFEND
SOMEBODY WHO IS MORE POWERFUL
THAN ME, BUT IDENTIFIES AS BEING
MARGINALIZED BECAUSE I MIGHT
LOSE MY CAREER?
>> Tucker: YOUR SITE MANAGES
TO BE CONSISTENTLY FUNNY, AND I
THINK PROBABLY MOST OF OUR
VIEWERS GET, YOU KNOW, "BABYLON
B" HEADLINES TEXTED TO THEM AT
LEAST ONCE A DAY.
DO YOU FEEL YOU ARE ON THE EDGE
OF GETTING YOUR BUSINESS TAKEN
AWAY FROM YOU?
>> I MEAN, THAT IS THE GOAL,
RIGHT?
THERE ARE TEN DIFFERENT WAYS
THEY ARE TRYING TO ATTACK
COMEDY, ONE OF THEM IS NOT EVEN
INTENTIONAL, THEY ARE MAKING
REALITY ABSURD.
THAT WHOLE OPENING YOU DID WITH
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS AND
THESE VIDEOS AND HOW FAKE THEY
ARE, IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO SATIRE
IS THAT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE BEYOND PARITY.
THEY HAVE TURNED REALITY INTO A
PARODY OF ITSELF.
THEN THERE IS AN INTENTIONAL
WAY, THEY FACT-CHECK JOKES, TRY
TO RATE TEMPLES, GET THEM TAKEN
DOWN FOR MISINFORMATION.
THEN THEY ACCUSE YOU OF HATE
SPEECH UNDER THE GUISE OF SATIRE
OR COMEDY LIKE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH CHAPELLE AND SAYING
HIS JOKES ARE BEYOND THE PALE
AND HURT PEOPLE BUT REALLY IT IS
THE JOKE POLICE, IT IS THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING "OH, HIS
JOKES HURT MY FEELING," THOSE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO DESERVE TO BE
MOCKED MORE NOT LESS BECAUSE IT
IS SILLY TO ACT LIKE JOKE
POLICE, LIKE JOKES ARE VIOLENCE.
YOU SAID IT EARLIER, YOU KNOW,
THE SPEECH IS NOW VIOLENCE AND
THE VIOLENCE IS SPEECH.
JOKES ARE NOT VIOLENCE.
THEY DON'T HURT ANYBODY.
IF WE ARE ALL EQUAL, WE SHOULD
ALL BE ABLE TO JOKE ABOUT EACH
OTHER INDISCRIMINATELY AND NOT
HAVE THIS HIERARCHICAL STRUCTURE
WHERE WE HAVE CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO
ARE OFF LIMITS AND WE CAN'T JOKE
ABOUT THEM.
>> Tucker: IF WE ARE ALL
EQUAL, BOY, YOU GOT RIGHT TO THE
HEART OF IT THERE.
ONLY IN A COUNTRY WHERE WE ARE
ALL CONSIDERED EQUALS CANNOT
HAPPEN, BUT WE ARE NOT